foreign
the three Muslims today brothers and
sisters we are going to go into
a really serious topic today
before marriage however before weaving
is that we all took in your vitamin D
for the day what's the camera bro very
very important we spoke about this
your vitamin D increases testosterone
levels
well only 10.99 a month what are you
doing
what are you doing
preparation for nickel what does that
even mean because you know you hear the
Hadith or the prophet saw Islam
mentioning to the Shabbat the young the
youth if you have the ability to get
married get married you know if you
can't then fast for very fasting
diminishes your sexual power
you hear in Islam not the Muslim culture
not some other culture study but
islamically or we're supposed to get
married young
so why is this preparation thing even
necessary
well I mean preparation for anything is
necessary any big stuff especially the
big steps and like even the small ones
but especially the big steps in life the
big changes you need some kind of
preparation uh if you look at marriage
and the rights of your wife or the rest
of your husband and the rest of yourself
right first and foremost
there's a lot there's a lot to know it's
a lot to consider and there's a lot to
be prepared for so there's a lot of
reversion that goes into each other
yes I mean
come on brother we're deep in the fast
right now we're starting again
but uh yeah so the question was why is
preparation for an account necessary
when islamically we're supposed to get
married
early on not delay marriage
okay so I think it's necessary because
it creates a deadline
like we all know how important date
lines up right we don't have a deadline
you're not going to get something done
if I tell you oh
you can get married whenever you want to
get married just make sure you're ready
okay
you don't know what it means to be ready
now you're gonna really look for it you
think oh I got the time you know like
other dudes here are getting married at
like 30 something years old 40 something
years old so I'm not even married at all
bro so you're thinking to yourself ah I
got time I can just chill I just gotta
make sure I'm ready though that's all
got to make sure I'm ready but what is
it
that's the real question like what is it
what is ready yeah to answer that we
brought here marriage uh counselor
around me to answer that question bro
what is he a woman
a adult female human adult female oh
okay but what does it mean to be ready
for the cat
well I mean it means a number of things
um first and foremost it's you have to
be in the right place islamically all
right is an Islamic term for first and
foremost to uh kind of
not symbolize but it basically means the
coming together a man woman it's not
linguistic people this is what is
referred to us but marriage between men
and women
in the eyes of Allah
itself is a contract and all that stuff
the ceremony and beautiful stuff with it
let's talk about that later so to be
ready for nikai you have to be in a good
place with Allah and your religion first
and foremost if you're not practicing
Muslim then you don't feel you don't
fulfill the criteria of the person you
want to marry because uh unless they
also fulfill the criteria that you're
both you're both at fault here the cross
Allah
he said that people will get married for
one of four things all right religion
Beauty status or well much of these
these foreign things he said if you want
to be successful go for the religion all
right marry someone for the religion and
he mentioned that character and Dean are
two of the most important things and the
scholars later on they discuss things
the compatibility so on and so forth
that you must be compatible with them
and how important that is as well so if
you yourself are good at the religion
you have good character you understand
your rights the rights of your wife and
not to get too technical but these are
things you need to know because Allah
has ordained them for us within marriage
right you have to know as a man you have
to have income you have to be able to
provide to protect and nurture to take
care of to be able to raise children and
all of these beautiful things because
you know even if you try not to get
pregnant there's a Hadith or someone
asked puzzles him well like quotas and
drops and he said that like you can do
it but you know Allah Allah will if you
end up basically impregnating your wife
and you have a kid that Allah he's got
to be prepared for that as well there's
a lot more that goes into it yeah 100
when you said status did you mean family
or yeah
yeah status is like serious winning
Trump yeah imagine marrying like uh the
elite of society
um
oh yeah I I usually hear a status yeah
usually your status when you when you
say status yeah
but anyway uh
quickly bro real quick
one of the four is obviously the most
preferred one and that's which one the
relationship so before we get into that
bro before you look for a spouse before
you I suppose before you go into
intimacy what do we do to ourselves
before yeah bro how do we how do we get
this preparedness um how do we ready
ourselves so I believe there's four
different avenues that we need to hit
and y'all some of you agree or if you
disagree I you've got the spiritual I
don't know
yeah the physical
mental
Financial
or the other thing that's spiritual or
physical mental and financial I think
those are solid table points bro yeah we
work with that yeah so let's start off
with the financial okay
a lot of guys think that they need to
have all the money before they get
better
we realize that this is not the case
most men have also realized this is not
the case this is not how a lot of these
things but
you need to have the intention that
you're going to have the money
right you may have the intention that
you're going to be able to support uh
this other person
you need to have also the capability
meaning that you're moving forward in
that direction that it looks really
weird then from your angle right
go ahead
go ahead it's perfect time too
all right so please feel free any of you
to jump in I don't mind
yeah I'll jump in here that quickly
about the financial specifically there's
a very beautiful verse in the Quran
right and it kind of gives the opposite
approach to what a lot of people think
about marriage and money Allah believe
it or not I think there's a lot of
people are not familiar with this Earth
Allah says even if two poor slaves
marry get married for the sake of Allah
Allah will encourage them all right this
is very opposed to what people say
nowadays you have to have X amount of
money you have to afford a wedding
that's as expensive you have to invite
this many people and then you have to
have a house and two cars and this is
not the other right
says opposite even if two poor slaves
the Americans
which doesn't excuse the guy right and I
don't I don't want anyone thinking
basically what angel said about you have
to have the intention of having the
money to mean that oh I could screw off
get married and then worry about finding
a job no you have to have some kind of
income but you just don't have to have a
full like you know a six-figure salary a
year uh Penthouse freaking a mansion 22
Bugattis
yeah you don't you have to have some
kind of income good character good Dean
and uh
questions
exactly yeah so it's like
that's I think that's a big problem is
we're always thinking like oh I gotta be
sad I gotta be set I gotta be set before
going in look the thing is like look
Allah is the one that provides it's not
you so you can't think to yourself over
there I have to be here and then I'll be
good to get married because then it's
like
um it's kind of going back to the story
of how they would
kind of like end the lives of their
daughters yeah because they they
couldn't provide for them yes or someone
their children
yeah but that was more so like the
status thing there is a verse in the
Quran where Allah says do not kill your
kids
that's that's what I'm trying to refer
to you that's the modern day abortion
bro that this is doing because I don't
know I can it's not a lot of stuff you
should be ashamed of yourself so that
right there bro like that's what I'm
trying to refer to it as like with the
finances like look we have the problem
yeah
be moving in that direction have some
source of income but like be very very
transparent with the woman that you are
trying to get engaged with I mean like
if if she if she truly wants the same
and you should marry you not for the
money she's marry you for your theme of
your character as well you should
understand and she will work with you
when it comes to the young man
you try to act like you have everything
you don't know if the person wants it
for you or for your wallet and that's
not a good place to be yeah and if
you're talking in terms of savings
versus income you're going to spend all
this money in this wedding and not have
anything afterwards or even worse you'll
be in crippling debt afterwards and then
your wife is Really Gonna Let You Like
boy what the heck did you do it's a
quick thing on the market think yes it
is a woman's right islamically speaking
to truth whatever amount she wants to do
yeah but it's all that is meant to
refuse any amount that we want to and
islamically speaking the Sunnah is for
the matter to be as best as possible
Allah puts more butter in the marriage
and that's how it should be right but at
the end if a woman if his sister does
want to have a high blood all Power Tour
no one's going to tell anything right
but as men we should understand that
it's not bad to have more of a man than
another sister but there's a limit to a
problem where do you draw the line you
know this is just me personally speaking
I want to ask you guys this question too
if all other variables are done aside
meh she looks the same she's physically
attracted to you she has Haya you know
she's modest she's gotten she wants to
be a good mother she's feminine all that
stuff is is the same what are the ranges
of the Mahal that you would be
comfortable standing on like a typical
range I think it depends on where I am
in life you know if I'm making six
figures a year I wouldn't have a problem
in my life you know 10K 20K or whatever
you know some everyone says you're
saying like oh you know ask for whatever
he makes in three months or four months
or something like that I'm not gonna
say that do it you don't do or anything
like that I think that's a little much
to be honest but um if I'm a millionaire
you know I don't think a hundred
thousand is a lot of money see the weird
thing is room my answer is not going to
change depending on my income level
because because for me I don't look at
it as a percentage of my income I look
at it as as a gross net percentage and
what I could do with that money instead
if I have a million dollars yes for sure
I could give you know 100k's chump
change however what if I gave her 10K or
gave 90k to put Masjid like to me I look
at it like that so that's why I said a
window arrange meaning kind of where you
are now to where you want to be for me
it would be anywhere from like I don't
know like three to five k like that's
that's my window but I still want to
know what you guys have to say yeah so
um I I do believe that it depends but
also like we will fight it in the sense
that like no matter how much money I'm
making it's not going to change that I
could be a millionaire but it's like
what was the money gonna be used for I'm
like I want to know foreign
that's true that's very true and I gotta
understand I really want to understand
like why why would you ask if Infinity
came back oh because I'm a millionaire
why does that change anything why why
would you ask me it shows about a
character bro you know and and I've I've
had a woman say like oh it's like
basically like you know if things go
sideways like she has to be taken care
of like she has to try and worry she has
to do this and she has to like this and
then she if you have kids then she has
to take care of kids like look
I get that
boy you shouldn't be going into it even
with that thought of like oh what is it
doesn't work out
we should have an escape bro we should
not but in in this case
realistically speaking
what's needed is not as much as what a
woman might throw a woman might say oh
50k and then a woman might actually say
that that's the thing of like oh well I
need to keep my life going exactly the
same as how I was when I was with you
like if you're a millionaire you're
obviously gonna be living like more nice
like 30k 40K you
um that's just facts unless you're very
like Frugal with your money right and
like at this point like
you can't leave the man and then also
expect that type of Lifestyle
and and one more thing I just wanted to
quickly jump in with the thing with my
heart is
you know I've wrote that I forgot my
whole song bro
um like we're sitting where guys are we
sitting here saying like you know it
shows a lot of character in a woman but
a woman would say also showed a lot of
character in the mat he's a billionaire
he's a millionaire but it's not willing
to get 50 000 you know how well is he
actually gonna treat me in marriage and
so on and so forth so I think it's it's
fair to at least look at it from that
perspective and um I you know a lot I'll
teach their own if you know you find a
sister
you know I think I think it's Easter on
actually if I'm a millionaire and a
sister wants 50k I'm okay with that it
shouldn't be an issue but if you want a
sister that's not willing to accept more
than a k 5K 10K uh then go for that go
for that there's no issue with that
because both men and women have the
right to to choose what they want I
think there's even I think there's a
verse of Quran
tells the man to you know or at least
encourages man to give a generous matter
right it's and I'm not giving anything
away from a general disregard what I'm
about to say until you confirm it right
but it kind of seems like Allah
encourages the men to give and
encourages the women to ask for a little
so you know what I mean so there's no
stress on either parties but it seems
like now there's the opposite women are
asking for so much and I don't want to
give anything at all
is a gift you know it's not see I I
agree with both of you I really don't
have to just be money yeah I agree with
Auto in the sense that it is a gift it
shouldn't you know it's not gonna change
much because it's like yeah 2
in the sense that if you do have a lot
of money it's easier to give that money
it's not like if you have fifty thousand
dollars as like yearly annual gross
income you have no reason to to take a
50 000 to go into Rebel launch for that
none of that if you're a millionaire
sure sure
but context that's not 100 and um
I do want to jump in and say on the
whole divorce issue
um that kind of thinking right I'm not
saying I don't know what you guys
opinions on this are but for any man out
there that line of thinking can't be
used unless you would not put a prenup
in your in your contract or whatever you
know you sign because if you're out if
you're a man thinking you know if we get
divorced I'm gonna lose half my stuff
therefore you put a prenup then you can
ask the same thing while you're going to
with that kind of mentality that
whatever at the same time islamically
it's easier for a man to leave a woman
than it is for a woman to leave a man it
sounds like a woman doesn't have the
right to actually just be like you know
I don't want to be with you peace out
unless there's a reason for it and if
there is no reason she has to actually
give up her mind right but if you you
know for a Goldberg runs you don't give
her her rights you know for example
you're like listen you're ugly I don't
want to be with you I'm not the major
with you but I'm not going to divorce
you so I can keep up my stuff you know
whatever it is
um then a woman actually has it right
islamically not talking legal in the
west but islamically to divorce you for
taking away her rights to actually get
to keep her man but if she's like listen
you know I'm not feeling it anymore
whatever
generally speaking she can't believe but
you have to give up the man so now that
all that's out of the way ladies and
Gentlemen let's go into preparedness
we forgot to add that the man who
doesn't have to be well it wasn't I
don't know who said it has to be
anything dollar yeah because it could be
service yeah it could be service
to be a service site you're doing
something for foreign
obviously I'm not saying we could take
the rulings from prophets from the past
right I'm not saying that to you that's
a uh what's it called a source of free
out here right but
um
he agreed to work for one man for x
amount of years
active service you're the one who gave
the shield yeah that was I think Ali
probably with the daughter of prophet
saws
there's a lot of units bro a lot of
currency then there's dollars yeah yeah
so yeah that was a slight twist because
we were talking about finances and ended
up going into the letter
um
but just Select Title in with the
finances having the uh
be actually doing something to make
money and don't get comfortable
we made enough some of our finances a
couple weeks ago yeah
we we had this button on here not a lot
of y'all like the the brothers himself
may Allah bless him he had mentioned
something that was very beneficial and
they said um there's no such thing truly
as maintenance
you either have your foot on the gas
or you have your foot off the gas you're
either progressing or regressing them
like there was no it's just mean this is
a myth that's what you said in this box
we still talk about that line until this
day bro they showed users
wisdom because whatever you're doing in
life you're either progressing or
regressing especially financially and
the thing with financially is it's like
a train when you shut off the engine to
a train a second leader is still
perceivably traveling as fast as it was
when you shut it off before you shut it
off Fox exit is probably still looking
the same but a couple seconds later a
couple minutes later dad's gonna be a
noticeable change right and the thing
with blindness is you don't if you're
already making 50k a week 50k a month
like you're not gonna notice anything
right away if your business starts
dwelling you know going down your
business is going to look the same your
banks are gonna look comfortable you
know for a couple weeks couple months
even even a year it might take two years
five years then you notice a change yeah
it's already too late bro at that point
yeah us so that takes care of the
financial
does it
like look if they're trying to get more
information on financial they can watch
the you know Finance we're just trying
to lay out uh the foundation The Avenues
here the most important before
the image I want to say one thing too
yes we'll talk about this after two but
financially speaking like you should you
should be able to provide the basic
things that Allah has made a story from
them the capability was so you know
provisioning protection like housing
food all that type of stuff medical
stuff all that type of stuff whatever
the things you can but you should also
have disposable income coming in extra
stuff to take her out for dinner and
let's say go on dates go to trips you
know spend money on her like treat her
good don't be stingy and cheap like a
miser you know like invest in your
family bro your family's like a garden
either you repost yourself which is
going to be good or you really put
yourself which is not gonna be good and
you want the food to be labor right
something I was thinking about just now
is that I think one of the best
investments
for us is our spouse 100 you know and
it's not just investing like money but
like the time that you invest into them
yeah right like the emotion that you
invest into them and like but like it
all just it's a complete returning like
what you give to them like if you
receive that for example I went to my
one of my boys and a cat
and the chef was saying before you know
while he was giving his his speech he
was saying that when you're looking at
one another you you either see your
Paradise or your house fire
and it's facts bro because if you
impress someone man or woman it's not
looking good for you but if you treat
them good the cool deal means the
paradise bro if you're serving them if
you're if you're going above and beyond
to please them if you're looking after
them if you're fulfilling the rights
yeah
a lot of men inshaallah I hope inshallah
will find that their wife becomes like a
good basketball a good foundation for
your hobbies yeah
exactly
it's being excited we got the spiritual
we got the mental and we got the
physical the physical stuff I want to
jump into next did they talk a little
bit about it a couple episodes ago
obviously but just to go a little deeper
into this
um I'll say three things number one uh
physically get to a point where you're
at least comfortable with how you look
without clothes right so you're
comfortable with your misses
um if you're a man and woman vice versa
so this is number one number two try to
get rid of any type of physical health
conditions that might get in the way of
your marriage let's say you have a
wrecked out dysfunction let's say you
have some other stuff you know get all
this stuff sorted out and then number
three for physically you want to make
sure that you're six feet tall if you're
not this doesn't apply you've already
lost get out of here bro just take a
backho yeah everyone
who's next
I would take that diagram yeah it might
take it seriously bro listen
you don't have to be six feet tall
you just gotta be five eleven that's it
doesn't matter I mean
it's on the different shapes and sizes
so
he's kind of like you've got women out
here that are like four foot eleven so
they're working 35 foot 12.
yeah but is there anything else in
physical do let me know yeah there is
for a man
a man should be able to defend himself
and his wife I think this is very
important because if if you're a man and
you lack disability
uh it's going to show on your character
it's going to show when your actions
your body language like when you get
into these situations or when some
things are rising
with someone is around you that maybe
they're threatening
your body language is going to show that
you but anyways you're going to show
that you're you're scared and you feel
threatened and you're gonna start
closing off that you might start
slouching more you might
you might as well yeah you cross your
arms you might like your voice make it
uh
I was thinking that same song brother
nah but your voice might get a little
like higher pitched and stuff like that
so
listen if I was a woman and my man and I
saw my man acting this way I would be
pretty damn scared I'm driving yeah I
wouldn't I would actually be more scared
than drive I would be like what did I do
I made a mistake like if something
happens like I'm not safe if I forget
you have kids yeah oh man that came from
Texas that's the only way so as a man
please like ensure that you are taking
adequate measures to learn how to defend
yourself
learn how to use your body you know
you can learn martial arts
Etc you do like more time because in
Jitsu that was a very very good as a
base but if you want to know more of
like the Bare Bones type stuff you can
get into
if I look correctly it's called
it's not about martial arts and that's a
martial arts yeah
problem of God is very legit because
it's allowing you to build more spatial
awareness ostrich awareness situational
awareness and understand like your
surroundings and how to use the things
around you whereas like martial arts is
good it's definitely teaching you a lot
of technique to you know showing you how
to do a lot of stuff but it's like let's
be honest like if you're gonna fight
someone like I'm sorry but if if I
wasn't gonna fight someone it's not
going to be like I'm not trying to like
like go like
I agree you know and and for anyone
saying oh this is not part of this song
this talks about peace listen bro listen
we're not seeing violence and and listen
you got to be capable of problems that's
what we're saying at the end of the day
in Islam we cannot be the transgressor
we cannot be the person that you know
hits first unjustly we have to be able
to defend ourselves and I know a lot of
a lot of Women full grow a lot of our
sisters and aunts and mothers are gonna
be watching and say oh yeah but in an
ideal world no one's even supposed to be
listen cut this idea up here so
we're going to get invaded we're going
to get you know countries are going to
come for us or other nations are going
to come for us all the people are going
to affect us they're going to come at us
listen the reality is you can be nice
you can be a pacifist you can have this
whole you know nice and rainbows and
sunshine type of mentally but you can't
guarantee every other man is going to be
like that so at the end of the day it's
just
being ready in case it gets to that and
then not wondering oh I don't have I
don't know what to do yeah and if you
look at like a lot of these people you
know depending on where they're from a
lot of the time the reason they're
Muslim to begin with is because there is
violence in that land Muslims tribe they
can't deliver the message they don't
want it and then there are warmth
Massachusetts
you won't even be a Muslim saying
there's no such thing as balancing Islam
look at the stories of the companions of
the Prophet saws
bro like you need to know these things
yeah and I want to hit on this point
that fire said like
your body should be good you should look
in the man you should like what you see
because if you'd like to see Partners
don't like what they see and this is
very important because this is what um
translates
into sexual attraction to one another
and that will lead to the intimacy
component and
the intimacy we all know how important
this is a lot of a lot of people want to
write obviously no it's not that
important like oh no it's about loving
each other
we expecting each other it's about
having communication communication
listen this these are all important but
like if you remove the intimacy like you
no longer have
there's gonna have a relationship you
have a friendship all those things you
just mentioned will go out the window
yes it will be gone but if you have
intimacy and most of those things aren't
there necessarily I've seen couples
where it works yeah I've seen couples
where it works very rare
what I'm saying these things will
developed work stuff not all that way
they don't have the intimacy no I said
I've seen couples where they have
intimacy and barely anything of the
others oh and I've seen them and it
works bro yeah but you can't go the
other way around I've seen couples with
all of the things you mentioned bro all
of the the things our parents told us to
have for women bro the intimacy yeah the
one thing our parents didn't talk to us
about because they were made me too shy
about it yeah
because I don't work bro yeah well we're
not told is that when you intimate they
put some band in his nationally and puts
a woman in your phone
when that's when that Dynamic is put on
isn't that misogynistic well I don't
care
once that once it's Dynamic is put on
like it's exactly how it should be and
therefore the respect comes yeah
therefore the communication comes
therefore like the actual you know like
cuddling you know the whole frame is
different It comes naturally and like if
there is none of that if you don't have
that frame like if frame control is
going to be way more different or way
more difficult I should say and if if
you guys aren't being intimate like
y'all are gonna be arguing
I go like
do you want to get married so that you
can argue
nah bro you got your mama you got you
you got your family but you can argue
with them if you really wanted to I
don't want to get
out yeah that's a proper man right there
Grandma I show lots of life if it does
get some argument you know it could pay
some receipts
arguments here we'll talk about that
later too I see too many men arguing
it's me saying oh yeah yeah this this
itself is an issue they literally sound
like females oh that's all that that's
the mental that's a mental voice yeah
okay so what's the physical growth
because you will get the body we got
self-defense what else did you say
I'm asking the body part you said
self-defense you said a few of them I
haven't gone self-defense
and now it's kind of like elaborating on
one of the ones that you said
I think another thing for body is
medical conditions physically speaking
if you have and here's the thing you got
some autoimmune disorder you got some
like really serious stuff I'm not saying
you got to get that handled a lot of
these you can't right well let's say for
example I've seen too many people like
oh they have this bad shoulder this bad
thing they might need surgery they might
need rehab you'll get these things
checked up bro you can't perform the
natural obligation when these things in
the way yeah that's um that actually
bleeds into the mental because if you
have these physical issues you're not
taking care of them like it's gonna
affect humanity and it affects Humanity
like you're gonna treat your wife very
differently and if you have mental
things before the marriage
change the problem it worse man like I
remember this one brother
he was uh he was in this relationship
everything was good he ended up getting
a spinal injury he ended up being a
herniated disc and bro like he stopped
working out he wasn't able to work out
for like six months really he could have
been like in the gym in like a few weeks
if he knew what he was doing but he
didn't start he didn't work out for like
six months and clearly that got to him
clearly because mentally like he wasn't
the same he was like tripping more he
was arguing more he was in his feminine
like he was complaining all the time
because I remember like
you we talked about this when you work
out you feel good yeah you know if
you're not working out you don't feel
good you feel kind of like trash so I
was like bro his relationship went
downhill and they ended up you know
splitting
yes it shows how that important the
physical is wow that's that's all I
gotta say
S I think that's a good segue into the
mental stuff now yeah so let's start
with that shotgun so take it away take
it away boy I'll tell someone okay but
yeah so I mean just off the top of my
head uh mentally speaking I think it has
a lot to do with you know be feeling
masculine being an investment energy
whatever you want to call it just being
a man right be managed to have a very if
this is the correct word stoic mentality
right they should be very firm in what
they think what they believe but at the
same time open to being correct if
they're all right we've talked about
good men and men who are good at being
men you need to have both you need to be
a good man who has his you know
mentality and perspective something that
is Islamic or the process and also how
the mental and Care character or I guess
characteristics in general that's the
process that I've had himself so I I
think I would start there and kind of
advising man to read this here see how
the process that I was with his wives he
was like and trying to implement that as
much as possible before you get married
and when you're out point where you can
interact with your family with other
Muslims with this correct personality
mentality character then you can begin
to say okay inshallah I'm ready to have
a wife you know that's the real
challenge
that's wisdom
come down
I want to say
for mentally
um
have beatbox for me but you don't have
to be the most intellectual learned
person out here or read books understand
the world around you that you navigate
right you're not trying to be finessed
understand what's what just a brother
Nami is saying but definitely have
matured in a lot of maturity does come
from education and studying and learning
things right you have to I'm not saying
you necessarily have to go to school and
in an academic world what you should
learn
female psychology male psychology human
psychology you should learn about social
psychology you should psychology is an
important thing right you should learn
about Finance which is just know the
world around you you're not going to
know without learning right which is why
I'm also on-pro women that go and learn
you know I'm not saying necessarily to
go to education and expense of solving a
family or anything like that but
definitely learn bro you got to know
your religion know the world around you
as much as you can correctly inshallah
so I think for the mental thing that's
important and also develop mental
toughness right if you have a dopamine
problem head over to my boy on House
channel
a-a-n-g-h-g-o right and you got to
welcome me in details videos and Shout
out what some of those don't be addicted
to your phone and all this that's one
thing to mentally you want to be
distraction free when you got a marriage
when you got a spouse nothing kills
anything then two people I was talking
to my wife about this the other day
marriages where there's two people right
you got a man and a woman sitting in a
room together the guys on his laptop
she's on her laptop or he's on his phone
she's on her phone right he's just doing
his thing let's say he's studying she's
doing her thing she's just you know on
her browsing ikea.com or something like
that there's no tension there there's no
chemistry there there's no sexual
anything there there's just two people
like roommates in a room doing their own
individual things but in each other's
presences because they want to still
have this facade of of quality time but
that's our quality time that's that's
not even present time and the reality is
a lot of people a lot of men this is I'm
talking to you men that mentally you
tell yourself oh you know I want to I
feel guilty about getting my felony time
so I'll just do my business calls while
I'm in the room with them I'll just edit
these videos while I'm with them or I'll
just do x y z one with them but the
reality is I would rather you tell them
you're busy be in the office or
somewhere else get that stuff done then
spend less quantity of time but it's
more quality and you're fully present
nothing kills it more than the phone
trust me yeah yeah just to jump on that
quickly this is not to say that there
should never be a time
it's just what is what he's saying as
far as I can tell is that it shouldn't
always be like that but from most of the
time that you're in the same room though
you should have some kind of nice proper
quality time attention attention love
Mercy the whole night yeah it doesn't
always have to be attention I'm not
saying anytime you're with your wife it
should always be intimacy no do stuff
with them watch you know movies with
them or cuddle or like you know do talk
about stuff have deep conversations but
there's so much idle time where a woman
is just on her device a man's on his
device no one's in the room present and
they just all it does long term is it
desensitizes y'all to be in the same
vicinity of one another and not doing
anything with one another therefore it's
easy to see couples that both have
careers spending 60 hours a week you
know they see each other in the morning
the bump heads during breakfast they do
their own thing they come at the end of
the day good night they go to sleep
this is being normalized and I have uh
one more thing I want to talk about when
it comes to mental there's no shame in
going to like on his channel and
uh or coming to our Channel or asking us
right and getting coached a lot of men
of course they don't know how long we
work they still watch movies and think
oh that's how women are and some know
related though a lot of I can't even
find myself doing the stroke we will
watch these dramatic freaking scenes
where a woman yells at the man
Emmanuel's back and they're so angry
yelling back and forth and bring that
into our lives if you want to drama show
you will be dramatic as hell you will
like whether you realize it or not will
be acting like this freaking dramatic
main character on this drama queen show
you don't want to be like that no you
don't you want to be like the brothers
here masha'allah you want to be like the
like uh brother Gabriel but definitely
guys get your mental health and mental
game in check
don't be this freaking crack that wakes
up first thing you do you go on your
phone I know a problem with that
sometimes and last thing you do before
bed is also on your phone but listen
don't detox is important
being able to disconnect from Dunya and
being present with family very important
um and I think lastly for mental I was
gonna say something real quick over bro
well
I was gonna say for what you were saying
is that there's a time and place for
everything
and
um I'd say the biggest thing for the
mental part is just keep working on
yourself and keep going
you know like don't stop
don't think that you are says it goes
back to the thing like don't take your
foot off the gas uh you got your phone
on the gas for your finances yeah you
should also be on my gas
for you mental health your physical
health be spiritual health
everything like we should always be
moving forward like and mentally like we
can think well right
but if you're not doing that in a work
if you're not constantly like every day
like reflecting and just like seeing
where you're at processing everything
that's going on in your mind like
you could be actually pretty damn
turbulent I'm not even realize that all
it takes is one thing up for these
sexual love
and like you don't want that in a
relationship it's just
it's not good it's not good to be in
that service in the state
because God forbid a lot of people take
it out on their spouse on their family
and I think if you ever hit your wife
raise your hand on your wife
um or your kids unjustly grow you're a
weak man trust me even even jealousy bro
we shouldn't hit our women bro what is
what is going on man we need a whole
episode now with domestic views and all
this stuff coming up too but on your
kids too listen I'm from a generation
where
disciplining your kids physically was
necessary at times and I know today you
got the whole culture they're gonna say
oh God you know your kids in a call uh
the cops on you listen I'm not pro or
Auntie but all I'm saying is you want to
be the type of father that your kids act
in a way that they don't even want to
see inside of you where you raise your
hand they don't even want to push you to
that point they're going to respect the
balance before you show them the bounce
and I think that's the type of type of
frame you want to have as a father yeah
something that I heard earlier about to
say a long time ago or where
um if you are a very like nice person
but then like when something happens you
live and you become like this monster is
like tiring he's like really you're not
you're not out for you baby and I know
what I'm talking about yeah so I was
like just think about it like if you're
a proper man and like something
following you you're gonna be assertive
you're gonna be expressive about it yeah
it's not gonna get emotional see like
how emotional is it it's like you're a
nice person and I know where somebody
gets you mad and you sleep you get from
someone where they're like yo I don't
even know who you are yeah you know so
it's like that's that's right we hate
these alphabetic terms because they're
cringe but bro at the end of the day
we're just talking about Alpha being
someone that's assertive says what he
says when he means it and a beta is
repressing doesn't so well it was saying
essentially if I'm correct was if you're
an alpha usually all the time and you
beta up or soften up every now and then
it's it's more like valuable and people
believe it but if you're paid all the
time 24 7 and you try to act off every
now and then it's kind of like no one
takes you seriously at the time you're
acting out of pocket at that point for a
long time I used to see anger as like
well if someone was angry I would be
like oh damn like
I'm gonna say bonus you know I was like
I went through like that abuse as a kid
I told y'all this and
um you know experiencing that angry 24
7. although I guess this is what a man
is I think this is what like magic
Community is right but then it's like
the more I go I I experience more anger
and even anger myself for such a long
time and I realized like damn like then
when they're in such an angry place
they're so emotional yeah and usually
when someone's coming at me like very
angry
oh man I can't really respect that I
can't really respect that and I imagine
like your father
you have kids
and you're like shouting at them yelling
at them like throwing everything and
like facing over you hitting them it's
like
yeah you're instilling fear into them
but at the same time like you're not
feeling respect
I respectful someone like like you said
you you can show this without even
getting angry like it could just be like
one little look and they know like oh
uh I better get my together here because
if not things are going to finish yeah
things are gonna get real nasty if I
don't you know so I think it's very
important so let me talk about ladies
and gentlemen the financial physical the
mental right we're kind of going from
least important to most important if
y'all haven't noticed it by now but
lastly the most important spiritual
I still eat a lot
beautiful
this
is my opinion is the most important
oh no you don't say the same man
yeah because I mean imagine you have the
best like the things that we just
mentioned but you didn't have the
spiritual you have the connections Allah
not having a spiritual action makes it
difficult to have lovely things it's
awesome like firstly look at mental you
know how can you have a good proper
perspective mentally if you're not no
spiritual related with Allah we have a
good question for Allah at least have
that spiritual perspective on life right
likewise bless you with you know
finances and a good body and even a good
message
although actually I take back the mental
state park you can't I don't believe you
can have a good proper mental outlook on
life or anything without having good
connection with God for us with us so I
remove that I take that back but
physically and financially alone I bless
you all right but are you really
deserving those blessings there's gonna
be America in that and that physicality
and the finances and all that if you're
not you know spiritually invested in
Russian Allah I love it yeah when you
get tested if you don't have the
workbook yeah that's it yeah that's it
well like when I was in Muslim and I was
being blessed with like certain things
about like when it got Stripped Away I
was just like I was panicking but I
didn't know how to handle that so I was
like now as a Muslim whether something
is given to me or was something's taken
away that's it
I'm grateful for that you know I'm like
that that adds to the mental health that
as a physical to the financial all this
other stuff so
yeah bro I don't know if I'm the only
one but
we went through a long day of fasting
and all I think it was the purpose I
can't know new things about that I get
tasted right now do you want to tell me
what we ordered
got a Popeyes chicken sandwich spicy
we got I got a four piece of combo but
I'm gonna be giving him my biscuit and
my my side because my Caucasian fries
black and ranch
there we go but I mean I think aside
from this what else spiritually
I mean the term spiritual is very
general right I think we should break
down spiritual what it means we don't
mean this is kind of new age stuff
we're talking about internet
spirituality plus religiosity obviously
yeah yeah or spirituality friend within
religious or a friend from the snap
right exactly
so you know have your obligatory
um taken care of Ramadan pray your
father is Alone
um obviously have the shahada that
should be the first one I should imagine
and
um if you can once in your lifetime with
your wife as well if you have these you
enjoy going and forbid people English
your partners with him uh Allah your
bare minimum is covered and then the
beautiful Hadith imagine that the most
beloved
that the ones that are obligatory and
then he mentioned the servant gets
closer and closer and closer to Allah
with voluntary acts of good and that's
when you strengthen the relationship
with Allah and you've got Allah to love
you more and be more pleased with you
and when you're at that point then
you're really excelling may Allah
just think about it man like the best
time in your life
or when you were closest to Allah yeah
100 100 well like the 100 the other
night man
quiet and I did a little meditation then
we just follow you before but
yeah
beautiful dog you even mentioned himself
I like
it just kind of hit differently yeah
it's a different vibe you know and like
you know imagine that like you treat all
your fairies in this way
imagine you're getting like that deep no
trouble bro like when I was in Thailand
and I was praying at the messages every
single prayer and during the 100 every
single night and I don't say this any
way you should perform both I say this
to just share with you guys how
beneficial and how amazing it felt to do
this like bro like I literally felt like
I was on cloud nine
and like no matter what happened
everything was good I just felt super
connected to a lot and like it's like
every little thing that was happening is
like I was just seeing like all like
it's weird we usually look back in time
when we can connect the dots right bro I
was in such a crazy like I guess in Iman
I whatever you want to call it that like
it's like I was connecting the dogs like
right there in front of my eyes as I was
seeing everything it was beautiful my
life it was beautiful
so I was like imagine that imagine that
right
you take care of the the spiritual
you take care of the physical if you
take care of the mentor and you take
care of the financial would you or would
you not say you are now more
than really
to be moved yeah more than ready bro
if Allah Wills inshallah you can have a
pretty successful marriage you know what
I mean and a wonderful family and what's
it doing well bro the the course of our
eyes yeah may Allah Grant your spouses
and children who will be the coolness of
our eyes and um I believe the ending of
it is allow us to be leaders for the
riches
said you had everything needed as a man
to get yourself ready
before marriage I remember it is
encouraged actually no it is
is
what you gotta say what it is first bro
it's not okay encouraged
to be very young
but with that being said Allah
foreign
foreign